i was reminded of this when president
trump sat down with
another guy well known for sports dave
portmoy
ceo of barstool sports had a sit-down
interview with president trump
at the white house and he asked yeah
actually was a pretty good interview
people were kind of joking what's the
barstool sports guy doing interviewing
trump he gave a great interview
he asked him specifically about the
tweets a question i think a lot of us
have wondered he said hey
man to man here do you ever send out a
tweet and then
regret that you sent out the tweet do
you ever wish you hadn't
done that trump's answer very telling
do you ever tweet out and be like wake
up oh man i wish i didn't send that one
out often
too often yeah you know it used to be in
the old days before this you'd write a
letter
and you'd say this letter's really bad
you put it on your desk and then you go
back tomorrow and you say oh i'm glad i
didn't send it right
but we don't do that with twitter right
we
put it out instantaneously we feel great
and then you start
getting phone calls did you really say
this i say what's wrong with that
and you find a lot of things you know
what i find it's not the tweets it's the
retweets that get you in trouble
you've been caught with retweeting
people like oh you just retweeted this
crazy person until you don't even look
you just press retweet there's fire from
the hip
you see something that looks good and
you don't investigate it and you don't
look at what's on the helmet
exactly right which is in miniature and
you don't blow it up and sometimes it's
but i i have found almost almost always
it's the retweets that get you in
trouble a lot of wisdom
in that whole answer it's not the tweets
it's the retweets that get you in
trouble in this culture it's
association there's guilt by association
which the left used to pretend they
didn't
like remember mccarthyism they didn't
they oh mccarthyism so terrible because
it's guilt by association
well now of course they inflict guilt on
us by association on everybody
if you've ever been seen with anybody
who's ever been seen with anybody who's
ever been seen with someone
wearing a maga hat you could lose your
job
and that that has permeated the culture
too
it causes it in a way to become more
relentlessly partisan
it causes you to lose perspective even
in a way that would help your own party
when you become so locked in that way
and then
and then the other thing that trump
reminds us of is
you can just undo the tweet you just
delete the tweet you can change
course and we don't really care about
one tweet or that tweet
but we're seeing president trump change
course right now
we're seeing him change course on his
campaign
go from weak attacks and what seemed to
be a weak strategy
to stronger attacks would seem to be a
stronger strategy you can do that i mean
we've got what little 100 days to the
election something like that
anything can change anything can change
in politics anything can change in this
life you can turn it around on a dime
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you